a lot of voicemails left during our
vacation at two one nine to david p
here's a funny little voicemail from
someone who's not anti-semitic take a
listen to this Oh David so um you know
I'm not anti-semitic or anything again
I got a matzo ball soup last week of
course you know but uh anyway I'm trying
to think there might be something to
this Jewish conspiracy thing um you know
if you look at how much money you know
the Democratic Party gets from Israel a
lot of money and you know it really
probably does not a lot of influence
over them you know I hate to get a bit
conspiratorial but maybe Jews are doing
something right
yeah well listen I'm glad sir that
you're not anti-semitic as evidenced by
you recently having eaten matzo ball
soup because as we know nobody who eats
Chinese food could possibly harbor any
negative feelings towards the Chinese
nobody who's into shakshuka or matzo
ball soup could possibly harbor any
antipathy towards the Jews but hey you
know what uh maybe there is some kind of
Jewish control conspiracy
I don't know that this requires much
more of a response we have a huge bonus
show for you today and tomorrow so on
today's bonus show I will tell you about
my vacation for the last couple of weeks
I was visiting my native land of
Argentina I was involved in a car
accident I was involved in a in what
else in many very unusual cultural
experiences I was involved in the midst
of a very unfortunate currency situation
in Argentina I don't know I was involved
in a whole bunch of stuff and I'll tell
you about that on today's bonus show
tomorrow we will hear about producer
Pat's vacation we will hear the good the
bad and the ugly of it and believe me
folks believe me when I tell you there
is quite a bit of ugly in Pat's vacation
story and we will hear that tomorrow get
instant access to both today and
tomorrow's bonus shows by signing up a
David
pakman.com slash membership I will speak
to you then it's good to be back